The following is a conversation with
Juergen Schmidhuber.
He's the CO director of at [inaudible]
Swiss ai lab and a cocreator of long
short term memory networks.
Lsts are used in billions of devices
today for speech recognition,
translation and much more over 30 years.
He has proposed a lot of interesting out
of the box ideas,
a metal learning adversarial networks,
computer vision,
and even a formal theory of quote,
creativity,
curiosity and fun.
This conversation is part of the mit
course and artificial general
intelligence and the artificial
intelligence podcast.
If you enjoy subscribe on Youtube,
itunes or simply connect with me on
twitter at [inaudible] Friedman,
spelled f,
r I.
D.
And now here's my conversation with
Juergen Schmidhuber early on you dreamed
of AI systems that self improve
cursively when was that dream born
man and was a baby now has not true when
I was a teenager.
And what was the catalyst for that
birth?
What was the thing that first inspired
you
when it wasn't?
Why I'm,
I was thinking about what to do in my
life and then I thought the most
exciting thing as to soul,
the riddles,
the universe.
And,
and that means you have to become a
physicist.
However,
then I realized that that is something,
even grandma,
you can't try to build a machine that
isn't really a machine any longer.
That learns to become a much better
physicist then I could ever hope to be.
And that's how I thought.
Maybe I can multiply my tiny little bit
of creativity and to engineer
team,
but ultimately that creativity will be
multiplied to understand the universe
around us.
That's,
that's the,
the curiosity for that mystery that that
drove you.
Yes.
Uh,
so if you can build a machine that lance
to solve more and more complex problems,
I'm more and more general problem
solver,
then you basically have solved all the
problems,
at least all the solvable problems.
So how do you think,
what is the mechanism for that kind of
general solver look like?
Obviously we don't quite yet have one or
know how to build one boy of ideas.
And you have had throughout your career
several ideas about it.
So how do you think about that
mechanism?
So in the 80s,
I thought about how to build this
machine that lance was so of all these
columns and I cannot solve myself.
And I thought it is clear that it has to
be a machine that not only learns too
solve this problem here and this problem
here,
but it also has to learn to improve the
learning algorithm itself,
right?
So it has to have the learning algorithm
and um,
representation that allows it to inspect
it and modify it so that it can come up
with a better learning algorithm.
So when I called that and metal
learning,
learning to loan and recursive self
improvement,
that is really the pinnacle of that
where you then not only you learn,
um,
how to improve on that problem and on
that,
but you also improve the way the machine
improves and you also improve the way it
improves the way and improves itself.
And that was my 1987 diploma thesis,
which was all about that hierarchy of
metal rnrs that have no computational
limits except for the well known limits
that Google identified in 1931 and a
four.
The limits of physics
in the recent years matter learning has
gained popularity in a,
in a specific kind of form.
You've talked about how that's not
really metal learning with,
with neural networks,
that's more basic transfer learning.
Can you talk about the difference
between the big general metal learning
and a more narrow sense of metal
learning the way it's used today,
the waste talked about today.
Let's take,
what's the example of a deep neural
network that has a learn to classify
images and maybe you have trained that
network on 100 different databases of
images and now a new database comes
along and you want to quickly learn the
new thing as well.
So when a simpler way of doing that as
you take the network,
which already knows 100 types of
databases and then you would just take
the top layer of that and you retrain
that,
uh,
using the new label data that you have
in the new image database.
And then it turns out that it really,
really quickly kind of learn that to one
shot basically,
because from the first 100 datasets,
it already has learned so much about,
about computer vision that it can reuse
that.
And that is then almost good enough to
solve the new task except you need a
little bit of adjustment on the top.
So that is transfer learning and it has
been done.
And principal for many decades,
people have done similar things with
decades met aligning.
True mental learning is about having the
learning algorithm itself open to
introspection by the system that is
using it and also open to modification
such that the lighting system has an
opportunity to modify any part of the
learning algorithm and then evaluate the
consequences of that modification and
then learn from that to create a better
learning algorithm and so on.
Recursively so that's a very different
animal where you are opening the space
off possible learning algorithms to the
learning system itself.
Right.
So you've,
uh,
like in the 2004 paper he described a
gate on machines and programs that were
right themselves.
Yeah.
Right.
Philosophically,
and even in your paper mathematically,
these are really compelling ideas.
But practically do you see the self
referential programs being successful in
the near term to having an impact where
sort of a demonstrates to the world that
this direction is a
is a good one to pursue in the near
term?
Yes.
We had these two different types of
fundamental research,
how to build a universal problem solver.
One basically exploiting poof such and
things like that that you need to come
up with a some topically optimal
theoretically optimal self improvers and
problem solvers.
However one has to admit that.
So it was this proof.
So ads comes in an additive constant,
an overhead and additive overhead that
vantages in comparison to uh,
what you have to do to solve large
problems.
However,
for many of the small problems that we
want to solve in our everyday life,
we cannot ignore this constant overhead.
And that's why we also have been doing
other things,
non universal things such as recurrent
neural networks,
which are trained by gradient descent
and local search techniques which aren't
universally adored,
which aren't provably optimal at all.
Like the other stuff that we did but
which are much more practical as long as
we only want to solve the small problems
that we are typically trying to solve in
this environment here.
Yeah,
so it's a universal problem solvers and
like the Google machine but also marcus
hooters,
fastest way of solving all possible
problems,
which he developed around 2002 in my
lab.
They are associated with these constant
overheads for proof search,
which guarantees that the that you're
doing is optimum,
for example,
that is this fastest way off solving all
problems with a computable solution,
which is due to a macros macro Ceuta and
uh,
um,
to explain what's going on there.
Let's take traveling salesmen problems
with traveling salesman problems.
You have a number of cities in cities
and you try to find the shortest path
through all these cities without
visiting any city twice.
And nobody knows the fastest way of
solving traveling salesman problems.
Tsp is,
but let's assume there is a method of
solving them within end to the five
operations where n is the number of
cities.
Then the universal method of Macros is
going to solve the same traveling
salesman problem.
Also within enter the five steps plus a
couple of one plus a constant number of
steps that you need for the proofs
archer,
which you need to show that this
particular class of problems that
traveling salesman,
salesman problems can be solved within a
certain time bound,
um,
within Oda into the five steps
basically.
And there's a additive constant doesn't
care for and which means as end is
getting larger and larger as you have
more and more cities,
the constant overhead pales in
comparison and that means that almost
are large problems are solved in the
best possible way of a today.
We already have a universal problem
solver like that.
However,
it's not practical because the overhead,
the constant overhead is so large that
for the smaller kinds of problems that
you want to solve in this level
biosphere,
by the way,
when you say small,
you're talking about things that fall
within the constraints of our
computational systems that they can,
they can seem quite large joints,
mere humans,
right?
That's right.
Yeah.
So they seem large and even unsolvable
in a practical sense today,
but they are still small compared to
almost all problems because almost all
problems are large problems which are
much larger than any constant.
Do you find it useful as a person who is
dreamed of creating a general learning
system,
has worked on creating one is done a lot
of interesting ideas there to think
about
p
versus np,
this a formalization of how hard
problems are,
how they scale this kind of case
analysis type of thinking.
Do you find that useful or is it only
just a mathematical,
it's a set of mathematical techniques to
give you intuition about what's good and
bad.
Hmm.
So p versus NP,
that's super interesting from a
theoretical point of view and in fact as
you thinking about that problem,
you can also get inspiration for better
practical problems.
All of us,
on the other hand,
we have to admit that at the moment as
the best practical problems,
all of us for all kinds of problems that
we are now solving through what is
called ai at the moment.
No,
not the kind that is inspired by these
questions.
Yeah,
no,
they have,
you are using,
um,
general purpose computer such as
recurrent neural networks,
but we have a such technique which is
just local search,
great in descend to try to find a
program that is running on the
[inaudible] such that it can solve some
interesting problems such as speech
recognition or machine translation and
something like that.
And there is very little theory behind
the best solutions that we have at the
moment
that can do that.
Do you think that needs to change?
Do you think that will change or can we
go,
can we create a general intelligence
systems without ever really proving that
that system was intelligent and some
kind of mathematical way solving machine
translation perfectly or something like
that within some kind of syntactic
definition of a language?
Or can we just be super impressed by the
thing working extremely well and that's
sufficient?
There's an old saying and I don't know
who brought it up first,
which says there's nothing more
practical than a good theory and um,
yeah,
and a good theory off problem solving.
Okay.
Under limited resources like he in this
universe or on this little planet has to
take into account these limited
resources.
And so probably that is locking a theory
which is related to what we already
have.
Fees isn't tightly optimal problems
almost,
which,
which tells us what we need.
In addition to that to come up with a
practically optimal problems over psalm,
I believe we will have something like
that and maybe just a few little tiny
twists unnecessary to,
to change what we already have to come
up with that as well.
As long as we don't have that,
we admit that we are taking sub optimal
ways and recurrent neural network isn't
long short term memory for equipped with
local search techniques.
And we are happy that it works better as
in any competing methods.
But um,
that doesn't mean that we would be,
think we had done.
You've said that an Agi system will
ultimately be a simple one,
a general intelligence system,
and ultimately be as simple one,
maybe a pseudocode have a few lines,
we'll be able to describe it.
Can you talk through your intuition
behind this idea,
why you feel that us as core
intelligence is a simple
algorithm experience tells us that the
stuff that works best as really simple.
So the [inaudible] ugly optimal ways of
solving problems if you look at them and
just a few lines of code,
it's really true,
although they ask these amazing property
is just a few lines of code.
Then the most promising and most useful
practical things maybe don't have this
proof of optimality associated with
them.
However they are.
So just a few lines of code.
The most successful and recurrent neural
networks you can write them down and
five lions up pseudo code.
That's a beautiful,
almost poetic idea.
But what you're
okay
describing there is this,
the lines of pseudocode are sitting on
top of layers and layers of abstractions
in a sense.
So you're saying at the very top,
it'll be a beautifully written sort of a
algorithm,
but do you think that there's many
layers of abstraction we have to first
learn to construct?
Of course we are building on all these
um,
great obstructions that people have
invented over the millennia.
Such as Matrix multiplications and roll
numbers and basic arithmetic x and
Calculus and durations of um,
error functions and derivatives off
error functions and stuff like that.
So without that language,
that greatly simplifies our way of
thinking about these problems.
We couldn't do anything.
So in that sentence,
as always,
we are standing on the shoulders of the
giants who in the past,
um,
simply fired the problem off problem
solving.
So much that now we have a chance to do
the final step
to the final step will be as simple one.
If we,
if we take a step back through all of
human civilization and just the
university chair,
uh,
how do you think about evolution and
what if creating a universe is required
to achieve this final step?
What if going through very painful,
an inefficient process of evolution is
needed to come up with this set of
abstractions that ultimately to
intelligence?
Do you think
there's a shortcut or do you think we
have to create
something like our universe in order to
create something like human level
intelligence?
Mm.
So far,
the only example we have is this one is
this universe in which we live.
You better,
maybe not,
but um,
yeah,
part of this whole process,
right?
Apparently.
So it might be the case that the code
that runs the universe Israeli really
simple everything points to that
possibility because gravity and other
basic forces are really simple laws that
can be easily described also in just a
few lines of code basically.
And uh,
and then,
uh,
the use of the events that the
apparently random events in the history
of the universe,
which as far as we know at the moment
don't have a compact code,
but who knows,
maybe somebody and the near future is
going to figure it out.
Pseudo random generator,
which is,
um,
which is computing,
whether it's the measurement of that,
um,
spin up and down.
The thing here is I'm going to be
positive or negative
underlying quantum mechanics.
Do you ultimately think quantum
mechanics is a pseudo random number
generator all deterministic?
There's no randomness scenario.
Our universe
does God play dice?
Okay.
A couple of years ago on a famous
physicist,
quantum physicists,
Anton Zeilinger,
he wrote an essay in nature and it
started more or less like that one
aussie fundamental insights,
ah,
see offset 20th century was that the
universe is fundamentally random on the
quantum level.
Yeah.
And that whenever you measure spin up or
down or something like that,
a new bit of information enters the
history.
I'll see you on it.
And while I was reading that,
I was honored the typing,
the responds and they had to publish it
because it was right that there is no
evidence,
no physical evidence for that.
So there is an alternative explanation,
but everything that'd be considered
around them is actually the random such
as the decimal expansion of Pi 3.141
and so on,
which looks around,
Huh,
but isn't.
So Pi is interesting because every three
digit sequence,
every sequence off three digits,
a p is roughly one in a thousand times
and every five digit sequence a p has
roughly one in 10,000
times.
What do you,
what you would expect if it was run
random.
But that's a very short algorithm,
a short program that computers,
all of that.
So it's extremely compressible.
And who knows,
maybe tomorrow somebody and some Grad
student at som goes back over all these
data points,
better decay and whatever and figures
out,
oh,
it's the second billion digits of Pi or
something like that.
We don't have any fundamental reason at
the moment to believe that this is truly
random and not just a deterministic
video game.
If it was a deterministic video game,
it would be much more beautiful because
beauty,
simplicity and many of the basic laws of
the universe like gravity and the other
basic forces are very simple.
So very short programs can explain what
these are doing and um,
and it would be awful and ugly.
The universe would be ugly.
The history of the universe would be
ugly if for the extra things,
the random seemingly random data points
that we get all the time,
that we really need a huge number of
extra bits to strive all these,
um,
these extra bits of information.
So as long as we don't have evidence
that that is no short programs,
that computes the entire history of the
entire universe,
we are as scientists compelled to look
further for that shortest program.
Your intuition says there exists a
shortage,
a program that can backtrack to the,
to the creation of the universe,
the shortest path to the creation.
Yes.
Including all the um,
entanglement things and all the spin up
and down measurements that have been
taken place,
um,
since 13.8
billion years ago.
And so,
yeah,
so we don't have a proof that it is a
random,
we don't have a proof of that it is
compressible to a short program.
But as long as we don't have that fruit,
we are obliged as scientists to keep
looking for that simple explanation.
Absolutely.
So you said simplicity is beautiful or
beauties simple.
Either one works,
but you also work on curiosity,
discovery,
you know,
the romantic notion of randomness,
of serendipity,
of,
um,
being surprised
by things that are about you,
kind of in our poetic notion of reality.
We think as humans require randomness.
So you don't find randomness beautiful.
You,
you s you find simple determinism.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Okay.
So why,
why?
Because see,
explanation becomes shorter.
A universe that is compressible to a
short program as much more elegant and
much more beautiful than another one
which needs an almost infinite number of
bits to be described as far as we know.
Okay.
Many things that are happening in this
universe are really simple in terms of
um,
short programs does that compute gravity
and uh,
see interaction between elementary
particles and so on.
So all of that seems to be very,
very simple.
Every electron seems to reuse the same
sub program all the time as it is
interacting with other elementary
particles.
If b now
okay,
required an extra article,
injecting new bits of information all
the time for these extra things which
are commonly not understood,
such as better tk,
then,
um,
the whole
description length,
awesome data that we can observe the
history,
I'll say you'll never else would become
a much longer and therefore uglier and
uglier.
Again,
simplicities elegant and beautiful.
All the history of science has a history
of compression progress.
Yeah.
So you,
you've described sort of as we build up
of distractions and you've talked about
the idea of compression.
How do you see this,
the history of science,
the history of humanity,
our civilization and life on earth as
some kind of a path towards greater and
greater compression?
What do you mean by that?
How do you think about that?
And deeds?
He,
history of science is a history of
compression progress.
What does that mean?
Hundreds of years ago there was an
astronomer who his name was Kepler and
he looked at the data points that he got
by watching planets move.
And then you had all these data points
and suddenly you out that he can greatly
compress the data by predicting it
through an ellipse lawn.
So it turns out that all these data
points are more or less on ellipsis
around sun.
And another guy came along whose name
was Newton and before him hook and they
set the same thing that is making these
planets move.
Like that is what makes the apples fall
down.
And uh,
also holds form stones and form all
kinds of other objects.
And some of the many,
many of these compressions off these
observations became much more
compressible because as long as you can
predict the next thing,
given what you have seen so far,
you can compress it.
You don't have to store that data extra.
This is called predictive coding.
And then there was still something wrong
with that theory of the universe.
And you had deviations from these
predictions of the theory.
And 300 years later,
another guy came along whose name was
Einstein and he,
um,
he was able to explain a way,
all these deviations from the
predictions are the old theory through a
new theory,
which was called the general theory of
relativity,
which at first glance it looks a little
bit more complicated and you have to
warp space and time.
But you can phrase it within one single
sentence,
which is no matter how fast you
accelerate and how fast are hard,
you decelerate.
And,
um,
no matter what is the gravity in your
local framework,
lightspeed always looks the same.
And from,
from that,
you can calculate all the consequences.
So it's a very simple thing and that
allows you to further compress all the
observations because suddenly there are
hardly any deviations any longer that
you can measure from the predictions of
this new theory.
And so on of signs is a history of
compression progress.
You would never arrive immediately at
the shortest explanation of the data,
but you're making progress.
Whenever you are making progress,
you have an insight,
you will see,
oh,
first I needed so many bits of
information to describe the data,
to describe my falling apples,
my video,
or falling apples.
I need so many data now,
so many pixels we'll have to be stored.
But then suddenly I realize,
no,
that is a very simple way of predicting
the third frame in the video from the
first tool.
And um,
and maybe not every little detail can be
predicted,
but more or less,
most of these orange blogs,
blobs that are coming down,
they accelerate in the same way,
which means that I can greatly compress
the video and the amount of compression
progress.
That is the depths of the insight that
you have at that moment.
That's the fun that you have,
the scientific fun,
that fun and that discovery and we can
build artificial systems that do the
same thing.
So measure as a depth off their insights
as they are looking at the data which is
coming in through their own experiments
and we give them a reward.
And in terms of getting ward and
proportion to this depth of insight w
and since they are trying to maximize
the rewards they get,
they are suddenly motivated to come up
with new actions sequences with new
experiments that half the property that
the data that is coming in as a
consequence is experiments has the
property that they can learn something
about,
see a pattern in there which they hadn't
seen yet before.
So there's an idea of power play.
You described a training in general
problem solver in this kind of way of
looking for the unsolved problems.
Can you describe that idea a little
further?
It's another very simple idea.
So normally what you do and computer
science you have,
you have some guy who gives you a
problem and then there is a,
a huge search space of potential
solution candidates and you somehow try
them out.
And um,
you have more or less sophisticated ways
of moving around in that search space
until you finally found a solution which
you consider a satisfactory.
That's what most of computer science is
about.
Power play just goes one little step
further and says,
let's not only search for solutions to a
given problem,
but let such to pass of problems and
their solutions where the system itself
has the opportunity to phrase its own
problem.
So we are looking suddenly at pairs of
problems and their solutions or
modifications off the problem solver
that is opposed to generate a solution
to that new problem.
And,
and this additional degree of freedom
allows us to build who you are.
Systems that are like scientists in the
sense that they not only trying to solve
and try to find answers to existing
questions.
No,
there are also free to pose their own
questions.
So if you want to build an artificial
scientists,
we have to give it that freedom and
power play is exactly doing that.
So that's,
that's a dimension of
freedom that's important to have.
But how do you,
how hard do you think that,
how multidimensional and difficult the
space of then coming up with your own
questions is as,
it's one of the things that as human
beings we are considered to be,
the thing makes us special.
The intelligence that makes us special
is that brilliant insight.
Yeah.
That can create something totally new.
Yes.
So now let's look at the extreme case.
Let's look at the set of all possible
problems that you can formally this
crime,
which is infinite,
which should be the next problem that a
scientist or a power play is going to
solve.
Well,
it should be
the easiest problem that goes beyond
what you already know.
So it should be the simplest problem
that the current problems,
all of that you have,
which can already solve 100 problems
that he cannot sold yet by just
generalizing.
So it has to be new.
So it has to require a modification.
On the problem solver such that the new
problem solver canceled this new thing,
but the only problem solve,
I cannot do it.
And in addition to that,
we have to make sure that the problem
solver,
it doesn't forget any of the previous
solutions.
Right.
And so by definition,
power play is now trying to search and
this pair and,
and,
and the set of pairs of problems and
problem solve,
um,
modifications for our combination that,
uh,
minimize the time to achieve these
criteria.
So as honest,
trying to find the problem,
which is easiest to add to the
repertoire.
So just like grads
Zudans and academics and researchers can
spend their whole career in a local
minima hmm.
Stuck trying to,
uh,
come up with interesting questions,
but ultimately doing very little.
Yeah.
Do you think it's easy?
Well,
in this approach of looking for the
simplest,
unsolvable problem to get stuck in a
local minima is not never really
discovering
mew,
uh,
you know,
really jumping outside of the hunter
problems that you've already solved in a
genuine creative way.
Okay.
No,
because that's the nature of power play
that it's always trying to break.
It's crown generalization abilities by
coming up with a new problem,
which is beyond the current horizon.
Just shifting the horizon,
I'm knowledge a little bit out there.
Breaking the existing rules such as a
new thing becomes solvable,
but it wasn't solvable by the old thing.
So like adding a new axiom,
um,
like what Google did when he came up
with these new sentences,
new he runs that didn't have a proof in
the former system,
which means you can add them to the
repertoire.
Yeah.
Hoping that,
that they,
um,
are not going to damage the consistency
also whole thing.
So in the,
uh,
paper with the amazing title,
formal theory of creativity,
fun and intrinsic motivation,
you talk about discovery as intrinsic
reward.
So if you view human as intelligent
agents,
what do you think is the purpose and
meaning of life for us humans is,
you've talked about this discovery.
I do you see humans as an instance of
power play agents?
Yeah.
So humans are curious and um,
that means they behave like scientists.
Not only the official scientists,
but even the baby is behave like
scientists.
And they play around with that toy is to
figure out how the world works and how
it is responding to that actions.
And that's how they learned about
gravity and everything.
And Yeah,
in 1995 we had the first systems like
that.
We just try to,
to play around with the environment and
come up with situations that go beyond
what they knew at that time and then get
a reward for creating these situations
and then becoming,
um,
more general problems,
all of us and being able to understand
more of the wild.
So yeah,
I think in principle that,
um,
that,
that curiosity,
um,
strategy
or sophist more sophisticated versions
of what a justice crime they are,
what we have built in as well because
evolution discovered that that's a good
way of exploring the unknown wild.
And the guy who explores the unknown
wild has a higher chance of solving
problems that he needs to survive in
this world.
On the other hand,
yeah,
those guys who were too curious,
they were weeded out as well.
So you have to find this tradeoff
evolution and found a certain trade off.
Apparently in our society there is a
certain percentage of extremely
expansive guys and it doesn't matter if
they die because many of the others are
more conservative.
And um,
and so yeah,
it would be surprising to me if I'm
okay
if that principal of artificial
curiosity wouldn't be present in almost
exactly the same form here
in our brains.
So you're a bit of a musician and an
artist.
So continuing on this topic of
creativity,
what do you think is the role of
creativity and intelligence?
So you've kind of implied that it's
essential for intelligence if you think
of intelligence as a problem solving
system is ability to solve problems.
But do you think it's essential,
this idea of creativity?
We never have a program,
a sub program that is called creativity
or something.
It's just a effect of what our problems
all of us do.
They are searching a space of problems.
Oh,
I space off a cannon dates off solution
candidates until they hopefully find a
solution to a given problem.
But then there are these two types of
creativity and uh,
both of them are now present in our
machines.
Um,
the first one has been around for a long
time,
which is human gives problem to machine,
machine,
tries to find a solution to that.
And this has been happening for many
decades and for many decades machines
have found creative solutions to
interesting problems where humans were
not aware of these,
um,
particularly in creative solutions but
then appreciate it that the machine
found that.
The second is the pure creativity that I
would call it what I just mentioned.
I would call the applied creativity like
applied art where somebody tells you now
make a nice picture of off this pope and
you will get money for that.
Okay,
so here's the artist and he makes a
convincing picture as the pope and the
pope lakes it and gives them the money.
And then there is the pure creative
creativity,
which is more like the power play and
the artificial curiosity thing where you
have the freedom to select your own
problem.
Like a scientist who defines his on
question two study.
And so that is the pure creativity,
if you will,
as opposed to the applied creativity,
which serves another
in that distinction,
there's almost echoes of narrow ai
versus generally I say this kind of
constrained painting or pope seems like
the,
the approaches of what people are
calling narrow ai and pure creativity
seems to be okay.
Maybe I'm just biased as a human,
but it seems to be an essential element
of human level intelligence.
Is that what you're implying?
To a degree,
if you zoom back a little bit and you're
just look at 'em gentlemen problem
solving machine,
which is trying to solve arbitrary
problems,
then this machine will figure out in the
course are solving problems that it's
good to be curious.
So all of what I said just now about
this pre one curiosity and there's
Seville to invent new problems that the
system doesn't know how to solve yet
should be just a byproduct of the
general signage.
However,
apparently evolution has built it into
us.
The cards are turned out to be so
successful.
Uh,
uh,
pre wiring,
buyers are very successful exploratory
buyers that,
um,
that'd be a born with.
And you've also said that consciousness
in the same kind of way may be a
byproduct of,
of problem solving.
Do you think,
do you find this an interesting
byproduct?
Do you think is a useful byproduct?
What are your thoughts on consciousness
in general?
Or is it simply a byproduct of greater
and greater capabilities of problem
solving that's,
uh,
that's similar to creativity in that
sense?
Yeah.
We never have a procedure called
consciousness and now let machines,
however we get as side effects of what
these machines are doing,
things that seem to be closely related
to what people can and consciousness.
So for example,
in 1990,
we had simple systems which were
basically,
um,
recurrent networks and therefore
university of computers trying to map
incoming data into actions that lead to
success.
Uh,
maximizing reward and a given
environment always findings a charging
station in time whenever the battery is
low and negative signals are coming from
the battery.
Always find the charging station in time
without bumping against painful
obstacles on the way.
So complicated things but very easily
motivated.
And then,
uh,
we give these little guys a separate,
we can't run a truck,
which is just predicting what's
happening.
If I do,
that happened that what will happen as a
consequence are these actions that I'm
executing and it's just trained on the
long and long history of interactions
with the wild.
So it becomes a predictive model.
Lots of wild basically.
And therefore also a compressor arsene
observations after awhile because
whatever you can predict you don't have
to store extra.
And so compression as a side effect our
prediction.
And how does this require network
compress?
Well it's inventing little subprograms
little sub natural networks that stand
for everything that frequently appears
and the environment like bottles and
microphones and faces maybe lots of
faces in my um,
uh,
environments or I'm learning to create
something like a prototype phase and the
new phase comes along and all I have to
encode the deviations from the
prototype.
So it's compressing all the time.
The stuff that frequently appears.
There's one thing that appears all the
time that is present all the time when
the agent is interacting with its
environment,
which is the agent itself.
So just for data compression reasons,
it is extremely natural for this
recurrent network to come up with little
sub networks that stand for the
properties off the agents,
the Hams,
you know the,
the,
the other actuators and all the stuff
said you need to better in code the data
which is influenced by the actions of
the agent.
So they're just as a side effect of they
are compression during problem solving,
you have internal self models now you
can use this model of the wand to plan
your future and that's what you also
have done since 1990 so the recurrent
network,
which is c controller,
which is trying to maximize reward can
use this model as a network of the
wilds.
It says model network Arthur wild
predictive model after wilde to plan
ahead and say let's not do this action
sequence.
Let's do this action sequence instead
because it leads to more predicted three
rewards.
And whenever it's waking up,
these learners up networks that stand
for itself,
it's like it's thinking about itself and
it's thinking about itself and it's okay
exploring mentally the consequences of
its own actions.
And now you tell me what is still
missing
missing the next,
the the gap to consciousness.
Yeah,
I,
there,
there isn't,
that's a really beautiful idea that um,
you know,
if life is a collection of data and in
life is a process of compressing that
data to act efficiently in that data,
you yourself appear very often.
So it's useful to a form compressions of
yourself and it's a really beautiful
formulation or cautiousness is as
unnecessary side effect.
It's actually quite compelling to me.
You've described Rnn ins and developed a
Lstm as long short term memory networks
that are there a type of recurrent
neural networks and they have gotten a
lot of success recently.
So these are networks that model the
temporal aspects in the data to temporal
patterns in the data.
And you've called them the deepest of
the new on that works.
Right.
So what do you think is the value of
depth in the models that we use to
learn?
Yeah,
since you mentioned the long short term
memory and the Lstm,
um,
I have to mention the names off the
brilliant students who has of course,
of course.
Um,
first of all,
and my first student ever set for Haida
who had fundamental insights already and
this diploma thesis then Felix
[inaudible] had additional important
contributions.
Alex Grey's a guy from Scotland who,
um,
is mostly responsible for this CTC
algorithm,
which is now how often use to,
to train the Lstm to do the speech
recognition on all the Google,
android phones and whatever and CV and
so on.
So,
um,
uh,
these guys,
without these guys,
um,
I would be nothing.
It's a lot of incredible work.
What does,
now the depth,
what is the importance of depth?
Well,
um,
most problems in the real world,
uh,
deep in the sense that,
um,
the kind input doesn't tell you all you
need to know about the environment.
So instead,
um,
you have to have a memory of what
happened in the past and often important
pads of that memory I dated.
They are pretty old.
And so,
um,
when you're doing speech recognition for
example,
and somebody says 11,
then that's about half a second or
something like that,
which means it's already a 50 time
steps.
And another guy or the same guys that
says seven.
So the ending is the same Evan,
but now the system has to see the
distinction between seven and 11.
And the only way I can see the
differences it has to store that,
uh,
50 steps ago there was an s or an uber
11 or seven.
So there you have already a problem of
depth 50,
because for each time step you have
something like a virtual,
a layer in the expanded and evolved
version of [inaudible] network,
which is doing the speech recognition.
So these long time lax,
they translate into problem depth and
most rotten ones.
And this wild I that you're rarely have
to look far back in time to understand
what is the problem and to solve it.
But just like with Lstm,
you don't necessarily need to,
when you look back in time,
remember every aspect,
you just need to remember the important
aspects.
That's fine.
It's a network has to learn to put the
important stuff and into memory and to
ignore the unimportant noise.
So,
but in that sense,
deeper and deeper is better.
Or is there a limitation?
Is there,
I mean Lstm is one of the great examples
of architectures that,
uh,
do something beyond just deeper and
deeper networks,
this clever mechanisms for filtering
data for remembering and forgetting.
So do you think that kind of thinking is
necessary?
If you think about it,
Lstm is a leap,
a big leap forward over traditional
Vanilla rnn.
What do you think is the next leap it
within this context?
So as Sam was a very clever improvement,
but lcm still don't have the same kind
of ability to see far back in the future
in the,
in the past as us humans do the credit
assignment problem across way back,
not just 50 times stuff.
So a hundred or a thousand,
but millions and billions,
not clear.
What are the practical limits as the
LSTM when it comes to looking back
already in 2006,
I think we had examples where it not
only look back tens or thousands of
steps,
but really millions of steps and um,
who,
um,
Paris,
artists in my lap,
I think once the first author of a paper
where we really was a 2006 or something,
had examples where I'd learn to look
back for more than 10 million steps.
Right?
So for most problems I've speech
recognition,
it's not necessary to look that far
back.
But the examples where does now,
so looking back thing that's rather easy
because that has only one past,
but there are many possible futures and
so our reinforcement learning system,
which is trying to maximize its future
expected reward and doesn't know yet
which of these many possible future
should I select give him this one single
pass is facing problems that the Lstm by
itself cannot solve.
So the other Sam is good for coming up
with a compact representation of the
history.
So far.
I'll say history and observations and
action so far.
But now how do you plan in an efficient
and good way among all these,
how do you select one of these many
possible action sequences that are
reinforcement learning system has to
consider to maximize reward in this
unknown future?
So again,
we have this basic setup where you have
one that we cannot work,
which gets in the video and the speech
and whatever,
and it's executing the actions and is
trying to maximize reward.
So that is no teacher who tells it what
to do at which point in time.
And then there's the other network,
which is just predicting what's going to
happen if I do that.
And then,
and that could be an lstm network and it
allows us to look back all the way to
make better predictions off the next
time step.
So essentially,
although it's predicting only the next
time step and is motivated to learn to
put into memory something that happened
maybe a million steps ago,
because it's important,
uh,
to memorize that.
If you want to predict that at the next
time step,
the next event,
you know,
now,
um,
how can a model of the one,
I like that a predictive model of the
wild be used by the first guy,
it's called it the controller and the
model,
the controller and the model.
How can the model be used by the
controller to efficiently select a ma
among these many possible futures?
So now eve way we had,
um,
about 30 years ago was let's just is
some model last awhile as a stand in,
as a simulation,
as a wild and millisecond by
millisecond.
We plan the future and that means we
have to roll it out.
It's really in detail and it will work
only if the model is really good.
And it will still be inefficient because
we have to look at all these possible
futures and there are so many awesome.
So instead,
what do we do now since 2015 and
[inaudible] systems control model
systems.
If you give as the controller the
opportunity to learn by itself,
how to use theory,
potentially relevant parts of the m of
the model and trying to solve new
problems more quickly and if it wants
to,
it can learn to ignore the m and
sometimes there's a good idea to ignore
the m because it's really bad,
it's a bad predictor and this
particular,
um,
situation of life,
uh,
where the control is currently trying to
maximize rewind,
however it can also allow them to
address and exploit some of the sub
programs that came about in the model
network through compressing as a data by
predicting it.
So it now has an opportunity to reuse
that code,
the algorithmic inflammation in the
modern or trying to reduce its own
search space search that it can solve a
new problem more quickly then without
the model
compression.
So you're ultimately optimistic and
excited about the power of our,
of reinforcement learning in the context
of real systems.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So you see rl as a potential,
having a huge impact beyond just sort of
the m part is often develop on
supervised learning methods.
You see rl as a,
uh,
for problems of self driving cars or any
kind of applied side of robotics.
That's the correct,
interesting direction for research in
your view.
I do think so.
We have a company called NASCENCE
nascence which,
um,
has applied during placement learning
too little audis.
There are these
where's land to park without a teacher.
The same principles where you were stock
cars.
So these little Audi is,
they are small,
maybe like that,
so much smaller than the real audis,
but they have all the sends Aras,
uh,
that you find in the real audi is you
find the cameras that Leanne sends us,
they'd go up to 120,
20 kilometers an hour if you,
if,
if they want to.
And,
um,
and they are pain sensor ass basically
and they don't want to bump against
obstacles and the Audis and so on as
they,
um,
my salon like little babies to park
takes the raw vision input and translate
that into actions that lead to
successful packing behavior,
which is a rewarding thing.
And yes,
they learned that.
We have examples like that and it's only
in the beginning,
um,
know this is just the tip of the iceberg
and I believe the next wave of ai is
going to be all about that.
So at the moment,
the current wave of AI is about passive
pattern observation and the prediction
and um,
and that's what you have on your
smartphone and what the major companies
on the Pacific of Mri using to sell you
ads to do marketing.
That's the crown,
a source of profit in ai.
And that's only one or 2% of the wild
economy.
Him.
Yeah.
Um,
which is big enough to make these
companies is pretty much the most
valuable companies in the hand.
But there's a much,
much bigger practice,
enough the economy going to be affected
by the next wave,
which is really about machines that
shape the data through it was our own
axons.
Think simulation is ultimately the
biggest way that that though those
methods will be successful in the next
10,
20 years.
We're not talking about a hundred years
from now.
We're talking about sort of the near
term impact of rl.
Do you think really good simulation is
required or is there other techniques
like imitation,
learning,
you know,
observing other humans operating in the
real world,
where,
where do you think the success will come
from?
So at the moment we have a tendency of
using physics simulations to learn
behavior for machines that,
um,
learn to solve problems that humans also
do not know how to solve.
However,
this is not the future because the
future is and what little babies do or
they don't use a physics engine to
simulate the wild.
No,
they learn a predictive model of the
wild,
which,
um,
maybe sometimes it's wrong in many ways,
but captures all kinds of important
abstract,
high level predictions which are really
important to be successful.
And,
um,
and that's what is,
what's the future 30 years ago when he
started that type of free sites.
But it's still the future and now we
know much better how to go there,
um,
uh,
to,
to move that,
to move forward and to really make work
in systems based on that where you have
a learning model,
lots of odd and model off the wild that
learns to predict what's going to happen
if I do that and that.
And then,
uh,
the controller uses and model to more
quickly learn successful action
sequences.
And then of course,
always this curiosity thing and the
beginning of the model and stupid.
So the controller should be motivated to
come up with experiments with action
sequences that lead to data.
Does that improve as a model,
do you think,
uh,
improving the model,
constructing and understanding of the
world in this connection?
Is that now the,
the popular approaches that have been
successful or you're grounded in ideas
of neural networks,
but in the 80s with expert systems,
there's symbolic ai approaches which uh,
to us humans are more intuitive in the
sense that it makes sense that you build
up knowledge and just knowledge
representation.
What kind of lessons can we draw into
our current approaches in four from
expert systems from symbolic Ai.
So I um,
became aware of all of that in the ats
and back then a lottery program logic
programming was a huge thing.
It was inspiring to you yourself.
Did you find it compelling because most,
a lot of your work was,
uh,
not so much in that realm,
right?
Is more in the learning systems,
yes or no,
but we did all of that is,
are we,
my first,
um,
publication ever actually was,
1987 was a,
the implementation of,
um,
genetic algorithm of a genetic
programming system in prolog,
prolog.
That's what you learned back then,
which is a logic programming language
and the Japanese,
the anthis huge fifth generation ai
project,
which was mostly about logic programming
back then.
Although in your network exists,
existed and,
and well known back then and deep
learning has existed since 1965.
Um,
since this guy in the Ukraine,
um,
eva can echo started it,
but,
um,
the Japanese and many other people,
they focus really on this logic
programming.
And I was influenced to the extent that
I said,
okay,
let's take these biologically inspired
Ireland's like evolution,
uh,
programs,
and um,
and,
and implement that in the language,
which I know,
which was prologue for example back then
and then,
um,
in,
in many ways as came back later because
the Google machine for example,
has a proof search on board and without
that it would not be optimal.
While mark was hooked as a universal
algorithm for solving all well defined
problems as approved search on board.
So that's very much logic programming.
Without that,
it would not be a,
some talking optimum.
But then on the other hand,
because we have a very pragmatic guys
also,
um,
we focused on recon you on and that's
where I was and,
and,
and sub optimal,
uh,
stuff such as gradient base search and
program space.
Rather than prove up the optimal thing,
things
that logic programming does it certain
certainly has a usefulness in,
uh,
when you're trying to construct
something provably optimal approvable
good or something like that.
But is it useful for,
for practical problems?
It's really useful for our theory.
Improving the best deer improvers today
are not neural networks,
right?
No.
Say a logic programming systems and they
are much better theater improvers then
most math students in the first or
second semester.
Hmm.
But for reasoning to,
for playing games of go or chess or for
robots,
autonomous vehicles that operate in the
real world or a object manipulation,
you think learning.
Yeah.
As long as the problem is have little to
do with um,
with theo improving themselves,
then um,
as long as that is not the case,
um,
you,
you were just wanting to have better
pattern recognition.
So to build a self driving car you want
to have better pattern recognition and
um,
and a pedestrian recognition and all
these things and you want to your
minimum,
you want to minimize the number of false
positives,
which is currently is slowing down self
driving cars.
In many ways.
And um,
and all of that has very little to do
with logic programming.
Yeah.
What are you most excited about in terms
of directions of artificial intelligence
at this moment and then the next few
years in your own research,
in the broader community?
So I think in the not so distant future,
we will have for the first time little
robots that learn like kids.
Um,
I will be able to say to the robot,
um,
lucky a robot,
we are going to assemble as much fun
that's takes a slab of plastic,
um,
and the school driver and let's screw
and the screwed like that,
you know,
not,
not like that,
like that,
like that.
And I don't have a data lover or
something.
He will see me and he will hear me and
he tried try to do something with his
own actuators,
which will be really different from
mine,
but he will understand the difference
and we'll learn to imitate me,
but not in the supervised way.
Um,
where a teacher has giving targets
signals for all his muscles all the
time.
No.
By doing this high level imitation where
he first has to learn to imitate me and
then to interpret these additional
noises coming from my mouth,
um,
as helping helpful signals to,
to do that banner and then it will by
itself come up with a faster ways and
more efficient ways of doing the same
thing.
And finally I stopped his learning
algorithm and make a million copies and
sell it.
And so at the moment this is not
possible but we already see how we are
going to get them and you can imagine to
the extent that this works economically
and cheaply,
it's going to change everything.
Almost our production is going to be
effected by that and a much bigger wave,
much bigger ai wave is coming.
Then the one that we are currently
witnessing,
which is mostly about passive pattern
recognition on your smartphone.
This is about active machines that
shapes a data through the actions they
are executing and they learned to do
that in a good way.
Okay.
So many of the traditional industries
are going to be affected by that.
All the companies that are building
machines,
well equipped for you as machines with
cameras and other sense auras.
And they are going to learn to solve all
kinds of problems through interaction
with humans but also a lot on their own
to improve what they already can do
them.
And lots of old economy is going to be
effected by that.
And in recent years I have seen that old
economy is actually waking up and
realizing that those are the canes.
And um,
are you optimistic about the future?
Are you concerned?
Uh,
there's a lot of people concerned on,
in the near term about the
transformation of the nature of work.
The kind of ideas he just suggested
would have a significant impact of what
kinds of things could be automated.
Are you optimistic about that future?
Are you nervous about that future?
And looking a little bit farther into
the future,
there's people like Elon Musk,
uh,
Stuart Russell concerned about the
existential threats of that future.
So in the near term job loss in the long
term existential threat or these
concerns to you or you ultimately
optimistic.
So let's first address the near future.
We have had predictions off job losses
for many decades.
For example,
when industrial robots came along,
many pete,
many people predict and lots of jobs are
going to get lost.
And in a sense they were right because
back then there were car factories on
hundreds of people and these factories
assembled cars and today the same car
factories have hundreds of robots and
maybe three guys watching the robots.
On the other hand,
those countries that have lots of
robots,
para camp,
Aton,
Japan,
Korea,
Germany,
Switzerland,
a couple of other countries,
they have really low unemployment rates.
Somehow all of new jobs were created
accent and nobody anticipated.
There's always jobs.
And um,
decades ago I always said it's really
easy to say which jobs are going to get
lost,
but it's really hard to predict the new
ones.
30 years ago,
who would have predicted all these
people and making money as a youtube
bloggers.
For example,
200 years ago,
60% of all people used to work in
agriculture today,
maybe 1%,
but still only,
I dunno,
5% unemployment,
lots of new jobs were created and Homo
Ludens,
the playing man is inventing new jobs
all the time.
Most of these jobs are not existentially
necessary for the survival of our
species.
There are only very few existentially
necessary jobs such as farming and
building houses and,
and warming up the houses.
But less than 10% of the population is
doing that.
And most of these newly invented jobs
are about,
um,
interacting with other people in new
ways through new media and so on,
getting new kite types of Kudos and
forms of likes and whatever,
and even making money through that Homo
Ludens.
The playing man doesn't want to be an
implied and that's why he's inventing
new jobs all the time.
And he keeps considering these jobs as
really important and there's investing a
lot of energy and hours of work and to,
and to those new jobs,
there's a quite beautifully put,
were really nervous about the future
because we can't predict what kind of
new jazz would be created.
But your ultimately optimistic that we,
uh,
humans are so restless that we create
and give meaning to newer in your jobs.
Totally new likes on faith,
things that get likes on facebook or
whatever the social platform is.
So what about long term existential
threat of ai or our whole civilization
may be swallowed up by this ultra super
intelligent systems.
Maybe it's not going to be smaller dub,
but um,
I'd be surprised if a b where we humans
were the last step and the evolution of
the universe.
And um,
you,
you've actually had this beautiful
comments somewhere that I've seen saying
that artificial quite insightful is
artificial general intelligence systems.
Jessica as humans will likely
not want to interact with humans.
They'll just interact amongst
themselves,
just like ants interact amongst
themselves and only tangentially
interact with humans.
And it's,
it's quite an interesting idea that once
we create a gi,
they will lose interest in humans and,
and have compete for their own facebook
likes on their own social platforms.
So within that,
uh,
quite elegant idea,
the,
how do we know
in a hypothetical sense that there's not
already intelligent systems out there?
How do you think broadly of general
intelligence greater than us,
how would we know it's out there?
How do we know it's around us?
And could it already be,
I'd be surprised if within the next few
decades or something like that,
the um,
the won't have ais are truly smart in
every single way and better problem
solvers and almost every single
important way.
And I'd be surprised that they wouldn't
realize what we have realized a long
time ago,
which has that almost all physical
resources are not here and this
biosphere but without
the rest of the solar system gets 2
billion times more solar energy than our
little plot.
There's lots of material out there that
you can use to build robots and self
replicating robot factories and all that
stuff.
And they're going to do with that.
And they will be scientists,
um,
and curious and they will explore what
they can do them.
And in the beginning they will be
fascinated by life and by their own
origins.
And I was urbanization.
They will want to understand that
completely.
Just like people today would like to
understand how life works and um,
and also,
um,
the history of our own existence and
subluxation,
but then also the physical laws that
created all of that.
So they,
um,
in the beginning they will be fascinated
by life once they understand that there
was interest.
I'm like anybody who loses interest and
things he understands.
And then as you said,
um,
the most interesting sources,
information for them will be others have
their own kinds.
So at least in the long run,
that seems to be some sort of protection
through lack of interest on the other
side.
And um,
and now it seems also clear as far as we
understand physics,
you need maton energy to compute and to
build more robots and infrastructure and
more Ai.
Civilization and I ecology is consisting
of trillions of different types of ai
and so it seems inconceivable to me that
this thing is not going to expand some
ai ecology not controlled by one ai by
trillions of different types of ai as
competing and all kinds of quickly
evolving and disappearing ecological
niches in ways that we cannot fathom at
the moment,
but it's going to expound limited
lightspeed and physics,
but it's going to expand and we realize
that the universe is still young.
It's only 13.8
billion years old and it's going to be a
thousand times older than that.
There's plenty of time to conquer the
entire universe and to fill it with
intelligence and senders and receivers
that ais can travel the way they are
traveling an hour labs today,
which is by radio or from sender to
receiver and let's call the current age
of the universe one Ian,
when Ian now it will take just a few
eons from now and the entire visible
universe.
There's going to be full of that stuff
and let's look ahead to a time when the
universe is going to be 1000 times older
than it is now.
They will look back and they will say,
look,
almost immediately after the big bang,
only a few eons later,
the entire universe started to become
intelligent.
Now to your question,
how do we see whether anything like that
has already happened or has already in a
more advanced stage in some other parts
of the universe,
the visible unit routes we are trying to
look out there and nothing like that has
happened so far?
Or is that charter?
What do you think?
We'll recognize it.
Well,
how do we know it's not among us?
How do we know planets aren't in
themselves intelligent beings?
How do we know ants seen as a collective
or not much greater intelligence than
our own?
These kinds of ideas.
And it was a boy.
I was thinking about these things
and I thought maybe it has already
happened because back then I know,
I knew,
I learned from poplar physics box that
the structure of the large scale
structure of the universe is not
homogeneous and you have these clusters
of galaxies and then in between the
these huge empty spaces.
And I thought,
hmm,
maybe say island's really empty.
It's just that in the middle of that
some ai,
so lization already has expanded and
then has covered a bottle of 1 billion
light years time visa and it's using all
the energy of all the styles within that
bubble for its own unfathomable
practices.
And so it always happened and we just
fail to interpretate the signs.
But then alarm of that gravity by itself
explains the large scale structure of
the universe and that this is not a
convincing explanation.
And then I thought maybe vb,
it's the dark matter because as long as
we know today 80% of the measurable
matter is invisible and we know that
because otherwise our galaxy or other
galaxies worked fall apart.
They would,
they are rotating too quickly and then
the idea was maybe all us,
he is ai civilizations that are already
out there.
They they just invisible because they
are really efficient and using the
energies are their own local systems and
that's why they appear doctors.
What's,
this is awesome at a convincing
explanation because then the question
becomes why is there,
are there still any visible stars were
left in our own galaxy,
which also must have a lot of dark
matter,
so that is awesome.
Not a convincing thing and today I like
to thing it's quite plausible that maybe
the first,
at least in our local light cone within
it's a few hundreds of millions of light
years and we can reliably observe,
observe.
Is that exciting to you?
They will.
Might be the first,
and it would make us much more
importance because if we mess it up
through a nuclear war,
then,
then maybe this will have an effect on
the,
on the,
on the development on the entire
universe.
So let's not mess it up.
It's not miss it.
You again,
thank you so much for talking today.
I really appreciate it.
It's my pleasure.